how can you find out your destiny using
Google Shannon from Cape Town admitted
that she sometimes regrets that she and
her boyfriend don't have an adorable
meat cute story because they met via a
dating him she decided to try and find
out would it even be possible for them
to have such a story and she did it
Shannon analyzed their locations using
Google's location history which had been
quietly ticking away collecting GPS data
in the background for five years you can
request and download this data through
the Google Maps desktop website
according to google Shannon and Dan had
a potential eyes meet across the room
moment a total of 41.25 times if you're
interested in how Shannon carried out
the analysis process we left a link to
the report in the comments the pair
crossed paths the most often in 2016.
Shannon even found out on what
particular day the story could have
begun it might have been April 6th well
look how close they were on September
14th I'm not sure if it's cute or scary
but it definitely shows that we don't
have any privacy leave your opinion in
the comments
[Music]